all right another candidate with a
strong performance tonight GOP Outsider
Vivek ramaswamy take a look one is we do
have to
Southern border build
s not enough
building cartel financed tunnels
underneath that wall semi-trucks can
drive through them we have to use our
own military to seal the Swiss cheese of
a southern border but we also have to be
honest there's a demand side problem in
this country too a mental health
epidemic I'm at family in Iowa two
parents Kathy and Derek they lost their
son Sebastian 17 years old he bought
Percocet on Snapchat
he died why did he die because it was
laced with fentanyl that is closer to
bioterrorism not a drug overdose that is
poisoning so it is our job to make sure
that never happens but it's also our job
to make sure that 17 year olds don't
turn to Percocet via Snapchat we have to
bring back mental health care in this
country
all right joining us now for vague Rama
Swami sir how are you good to see you
Sean you just told me your favorite part
of the debate was after the debate when
your son came on stage it was the last
five minutes of it when he came on I saw
him sitting quietly in the front row
he's three years old and that's about as
well behaved as I've seen him in a long
time I'm proud of him he's at the Reagan
Library I wouldn't expect that list one
of the more contentious moments was you
and Nikki Haley Nikki saying every time
I hear you I feel Dumber uh we can't
trust you Vivek so you came under some
fire tonight what's your reaction to
that why so and uh feeling Dumber that's
actually the first time I've actually
ever heard that so I'll take that as a
first but Sean my view tonight was there
were a lot of personal insults coming my
way that's okay these are still good
people I respect the policy
disagreements that we had but I'm not
running against any of them I'm running
for this country and I think part of
what you saw is I am the new guy and I
do have to earn the trust of the voters
at home
because that stuck out that that moment
struck me you were sending a message
maybe I come off as a little I don't
know it all you know at all that's right
by the way I'm a talk show host every
talk shows you'll ever meet comes off as
a know-it-all so I can identify the
thing Sean is but what did you why do
you want what is it that you really want
to tell people that don't know you that
see you and that see you're outspoken
what do you what do you really want to
communicate I think that having strong
convictions and being humble about your
actual scope of knowledge those aren't
incompatible those go together and the
way I've built my business is I've
surrounded myself with people who
challenge me the best and brightest who
actually push me to be the best version
of myself and so when I'm
commander-in-chief if I'm successfully
elected I expect there will be several
people on that stage who I'll be relying
on in the same way so their attacks
don't you sure I said I didn't say all
of them I didn't say all of them but
even people who are off that stage so I
think that we're going to require taking
the America first movement to the next
level Sean but I'm going to do things a
little differently on my watch I'm going
to reunite this party and I'm going to
reunite this country and I do think it's
going to take somebody of a new
generation somebody whose best days are
still yet ahead in life
to see a country whose best days are
still yet ahead too I truly believe that
so I'm not one of these it's morning in
America people it's not morning in
America right now but it can be and I
think it's going to take a new job I
would say America has been in a
precipitous decline doesn't have to stay
that way on every listen and this is the
biggest problem every single thing that
we are dealing with that's going wrong
our borders
these are all self-inflicted wounds
Energy prices have you seen the price of
a gallon of gasoline out here absolutely
every prop our Law and Order safety
secure in our school system
that's the good news is it's fixable
right drill Frac burn coal Embrace
nuclear stop paying people more money to
stay at home than to go to work abandon
the climate cult that shackles the
United States while leaving China
untouched declare economic independence
from our enemy communist China who we
cannot depend for the shoes on our feet
to the phones in our pockets and the
drugs and the medicines we take to the
pharmaceutical supply chain which I of
course understand and know well the same
country that's poisoning the illegal
Trump put a tariff on them Trump made
them pay I think we've got to go further
than that I think the answer is what's
further well I think what is further is
total decoupling it's not by land in
this country or will not turn companies
into lobbying ponds we're going to hold
them accountable for unleashing hell on
the world for the covid-19 pandemic we
can't forget about that one shot on is
that that was catastrophe inflicted on
us and if we don't hold them accountable
for that we can expect worse in the
future now I want to say this in the
Reagan Library tonight yeah Reagan said
this about the Soviet Union how cool is
that with this jet hanging on it was
over your head yeah
it looked it was it was a beautiful
sight it is it was inspiring to me what
did he say his foreign policy strategy
against the Soviet Union was we win they
lose well here's my next question is the
threat I say to communist China we win
they lose that's how I'm going to lead
okay there was a guy that wasn't on that
stage tonight yes and he's got a massive
lead against all of you on that stage
yes okay
that's that's obstacle number one well
look I the way I look at it is I was a
little different than everybody else on
the stage the reason Donald Trump's in
the lead let's be honest is that he was
an excellent president but I'm an
America First conservative not a trump
first conservative and I think we have
to reunite this country and reach the
next Generation to take our America
First agenda to the next level so I will
honor Donald Trump and his legacy more
than anybody else do you find out
further do you believe that these
indictments are
and I will pardon him on day one I said
that at the last debate I stand by it
and one of the things I noticed tonight
is that I think they're all I asked you
to be vice president what would you say
I would ask him to be my most important
mentor and advisor in the first year
when I'm in office okay because that's
what a lot if you don't make it for some
reason so Sean you don't want to answer
that question no this isn't about me and
it's not about Trump I'm just asking
bigger than us right and so my belief is
I will be best positioned to reunite
this country as our next
commander-in-chief but I am humble
enough to surround myself with the very
best and Trump is absolutely on that
list I thought if I had to say what I
thought your best moment was is when you
would just open you know I may come off
as a know it all this and that I have to
introduce myself I have to prove myself
I thought that was a good moment for you
I appreciate him being an assistant
Candor all right we appreciate it as
always thank you Sean appreciate that
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else